now this is a recipe for mayhem at the
very moment the very moment that our
country needs a strong and stable
government we risk a weak and unstable
one push to the left by its allies and
open to a daily dose of political
blackmail the Scott Nats at Westminster
will have one key objective to entrench
SNP popularity in Scotland ahead of next
year's Scottish Parliament elections
that's their principal aim and it
creates a wretched dilemma for labour
for whilst SNP support might put Mr
Miliband in number 10 the payback for
labour will be very costly
indeed for with every bribe that Labour
concede the more popular the SNP will
become and the more popular they become
the more likely it will be that they
will win the Scottish Parliament
elections in May of next year and if the
SNP do win next year what will they do
with their victory I can tell you
they'll demand a further referendum on
independence they will either put that
in their manifesto or they will claim it
as an entitlement of their win in the
Scottish elections and so that once in a
generation vote will become a once-in-a
Parliament vote that's their plan